I can hear you being quiet mom I am hope I
didn't ice your game man no one my age says
those words in that order it's just hard to see
my little man not be my little boy all the time
for years I've been taking care of this little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs
wherever he wants to be
he wants to go out into the
world and do great big things
not bad kid and what I worry about most I love you
miles it was they won't look out for you like us
miles wanna get out of here wherever you go
from here you have to promise to take care
of that little boy for me make sure
he never forgets where he came from
and he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone tell
him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles I promise
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they just
dropped our new Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs a
billion versions of Spider-Man in there so we'll
break it all down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos even though
the first like 90 of the trailer is meant to be
a flashback to show you what's happened to miles
in his Earth the ultimate Earth since the events
of the first movie like him just being Spider-Man
trying to be a better Spider-Man the last little
bit of the trailer starts to tease you about what
the actual plot of the movie is and the whole idea
is that he runs a foul of Spider-Man 2099 who we
saw in the post-credit scene from the first movie
who's with another team of Multiverse versions
of Spider-Man trying to clean up the damage to
the Multiverse that the reactor caused during the
events of the first movie they don't explain what
it is that he's doing that goes against what
they want to do like what puts them at odds
but the whole idea is that Spider-Man 2099
that's leading this Multiverse team thinks
that they're doing the right thing which is why
you hear that line in the trailer where he says
what do you think that you're doing we're the
good guys in the way that spider Gwen is talking
to him makes it sound like they're not being the
good guys that's a very Captain America Civil War
type of argument that like Iron Man and Captain
America would have like do we kill somebody if
it's going to protect the Multiverse or do we
allow them to live it might have something to
do with how they deal with the villain of the
film who's meant to be the spot character who
will also be the villain of the second film
because it's a two-part film remember they're
doing the Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game thing with Spider-Man across the spiderverse
so part one is just called to cross the spider
verse part 2 is called beyond the spider verse
that'll release in 2020 for just a year later
so even though they make it seem like this
Multiverse group of Spider-Man are the villains
of this film they're not it's more of a Captain
America Civil War situation but just starting
at the beginning of the trailer they start with
the same type of logo it's a brand new version of
the logo but it's the same type of logo that they
did in the first film where they glitched between
the different types of comic book art it's been a
couple years since the events of the first movie
Miles Morales is a little bit older he's tried
to be Spider-Man for the past couple of years
you see a couple of his adventures throughout
this first part of the trailer as his mother is
talking to him being sad that he's growing up so
fast fast the other added detail here too if you
turn the subtitles on on the Twitter version of
the trailer the subtitles that they uploaded for
the trailer are actually in the comic book style
of the movie The Brooklyn Jersey he's wearing is
because that's where he's from he's from Brooklyn
the number 42 is the number 42 spider that bit
Spider-Man to give him the powers it was also
meant to be a reference in the original comic
book version of the character the comic book
Miles Morales to Jackie Robinson's number 42 which
is also the Brooklyn Jersey another Marvel Easter
egg who was played by Chadwick Boseman a couple
years ago before he passed away may he rest in
peace they flash back to the events of the first
movie where he gets the Halloween costume great
Stanley Cameo especially the moment where he
says no refunds may he rest in peace basically
a quick recap of the events of the first movie
this scene in his lab of all the costumes and
their cases also foreshadowing the many versions
of Spider-Man that we're going to see from the
Multiverse also most of the major characters from
the first movie came back like Peter B Parker is
back wearing the baby carrier because at the end
of the first movie he got back together with his
version of Mary Jane they had a child together
it's probably a version of Mayday Parker from
the comics like I'm gonna come help you save the
Multiverse but I'm on babysitting duty today so I
gotta bring the baby with me but don't worry the
baby has powers too it could take care of itself
like give me baby Yoda but Spider-Man she also
gets Spider-Man's powers and becomes a version
of Spider-Man when she gets older this is where
they show you one of the adventures that he had
after the events of the first movie Saving a group
of people from this cab it looks like he's already
got his new costume during this just because
the logo looks a little bit different from the
original costume that he had spray painted
on this is the scene from the first trailer
that we saw where spider-gwen comes to visit him
after the events of the first movie to just see
what's been going on this is some of the footage
that we saw during the first trailer with him
entering the spider-verse traveling across the
Multiverse when we're talking about across the
spider verse into the spider-verse comics it's
called the spider-verse it's a different way of
describing the Multiverse but it's the same basic
concept the way they're able to do that is they
use the web wear wrist watches that you saw in the
post-credits scene that Spider-Man 2099 created it
allows them to travel the multi verse at will
that even though most of the footage focuses
on this Multiverse base where all the different
Multiverse versions of Spider-Man have assembled
they said the movie would have six distinct art
styles for all the different universes that they
travel to the ones that we know about are the
main Ultimate Universe that Miles Morales comes
from Spider-Man India's universe that we saw in
the first trailer Spider-Man 2099's universe in
Nueva York we also saw that in the last trailer
Spider Gwen's Universe Earth 65 and then we don't
know what the other two are like maybe the spots
home Universe because he's meant to be the villain
of the film and you can guess what the other
art style is going to be like what the other
universe will visit but remember the whole idea
is that Spider-Man 2099 has assembled all these
different Spider-Man from across the Multiverse
to fix the damage that the reactor caused Kingpin
built in the first movie as they zoom out they
start showing you many many different versions
of Spider-Man pretty much every single version
you could think of from the comics like even
if Spider-Man PS4 from the video game here his
costume was actually featured during the first
movie if you remember so they already kind
of canonized the events of the game came to
this Multiverse the one that we saw in Peter
Parker's lab is just one that he wore at some
point during his history they even have a version
of spider cop which is relatively new that they
also feature in the Spider-Man PS4 game and they
have the bombastic Bag Man even though he's not
wearing the Fantastic Four part of the costume
he's just wearing the bag part that was from an
adventure in the comics where Spider-Man didn't
have his costume available and he was leaving the
Fantastic Four so he needed a bag to hide his
identity so we wore a regular brown bag while
he webbed slung home this is Miles still inside
that same lab area wearing his new costume with
spider Gwen Peter B Parker comes back he's wearing
the baby carriage but he's walking upside down
remember these are all versions of Spider-Man with
versions of Spider-Man's Powers slightly different
powers each but very similar ones that's why you
see them walking casually upside down all over the
place obviously the joke here is that the two of
them are sitting upside down because they're using
their powers to stick to The Ledger then I believe
that this is meant to be the spider-verse version
of Issa Ray's Jessica Drew character like this is
a version of Spider-Woman but it's a Multiverse
Jessica drew it looks like she's attacking a
version of the vulture this is Miles and Gwen
confronting Spider-Man 2099 without his mask
on the picture he's looking at here looks like
a version of his daughter like he lost his
daughter at some point this is his hand he's
wearing one of the web wear wrist watches he
gets to go out on another mission with Jessica
Drew and this is Peter B Parker miles and Gwen
talking to him Spider-Man 2099 in this Nexus
area where he gets ready to go out on another
mission with portals to a bunch of different
universes obviously the way they visualize this
is meant to be a Easter egg for the web of life
and Destiny like as a giant Cosmic spider web
that connects the entire Multiverse the Hawaii
of his mother's voice over speech is meant to
be the idea that he belongs here just as much
as the other versions of Spider-Man belong here I
think that's going to be one of the conflicts of
the film where Spider-Man 2099 basically tells
him to go home and stop messing with stuff the
way the producers explained it is that spider
Gwen has been invited to join this Multiverse
spider Force by Spider-Man 2099 with all the
other versions but miles isn't not allowed on
the team so it's like The Simpsons episode with
the no homers club like oh you're letting in all
the other versions of Spider-Man why not me too I
now call to order the first meeting of the ancient
Mystic Society of no homers hey fellas can I join
it's on it no homers and then they show the scene
where basically like every single version of
Spider-Man from the Multiverse goes after Miles
Morales because he's trying to do something
that goes against whatever their mission is
like I said it's going to be very Captain America
Civil War type of conflict where you have like
two groups of people trying to do the good thing
but being at odds with each other over what it is
that they're supposed to do so like Spider-Man
2099 isn't supposed to be evil or anything like
that even though they make him seem kind of
like a villain during this and it's meant to
be pretty much every single version of Spider-Man
you've ever seen in the spider-verse comics or in
the Spider-Man comic books in general this is
just another scene of Spider-Man 2099 without
his mask off all pissed off at miles and it is
Oscar Isaac coming back to voice the character
they flash a couple different comic book Styles
as they get ready to travel across the universes
all these scenes are from the first trails
that we saw with Spider-Man 2099 grabbing
Miles Morales and throwing him back to their
base they're inside Spider-Man 2099's universe
here in New Wave at York there's so many
different versions of Spider-Man you could
probably watch the trailer a billion times
and spot more of them like I said pretty much
every single version you've ever thought of and
most of the ones that are in the PS4 game and a
bunch of them are versions wearing the costumes
you saw in Peter Parker's underground bunker in
the first movie just from the Multiverse there's
werewolf Spider-Man remember we have Ben Reilly
in the movie I already talked about Jessica Drew
there's Spider-Man Unlimited from that cartoon
there's a version of Spider-Man from Spider-Man
the Animated Series in the 90s there's probably
versions of a couple of the cartoon versions
of Spider-Man the only one that we don't see
in the trailer that I can't find is Japanese
supaida man they said he'd be in the movie but
I didn't spot him in the trailer but he's probably
somewhere in the background here post all the ones
that you spotted in the trailer down below in
the comments and let me know which one is your
favorite version of Spider-Man man they posted
another video in addition to the trailer I'll
do a video for that next that should post in the
next day or so make sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here to watch that video I'll update the link
as soon as I post it and clicking for that other
Spider-Man across the spider-verse trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!